good morning believe nation today's
message is have gold over to you Eric
worry my future plan is about this thick
tight it's usually about 40 pages or so
and it includes everything and today
more than ever will you find with top
leaders will your time find with
successful people is their
forward-thinking their future thinking
and that that future starts to pull them
towards those objectives so I set my
goals pretty high and I've set my
calendar far in advance I'm planning I
still have some spontaneity room for
spontaneity but more and more as the the
the demands on my time are growing
exponentially I have to plan and and
what I've done this for gosh 25 years to
look back and look forward look back
take inventory be honest and look
forward and map it out so I want you to
think about short-term midterm long-term
goals for you personally and for your
team when you have specific goals you're
much more likely to follow through when
you know where you're going and you
clearly defined it you're much more
likely to achieve and hit that target
the challenge then becomes making sure
you have meaningful goals that support
you I look at my mastermind group
there's a collection of entrepreneurs we
get together once a month and we have
goals of the part of what we do there's
short-term goals and what you're going
to get done before the end of next month
so before you come and meet at the next
meeting here the three things that you
need to do in your business in your life
to make some forward progress and itself
so fine it's not me saying here's your
goals you need to come with your goals
and say excuse or I need to get done
before the end of our next meeting and
then we have an annual poll by December
31st of this year what is your business
and we force it to be a quantifiable
wool it has to be specific we have to be
able to measure it's not just I want to
feel happy about my life gotta be
something that is paintable most people
pick a revenue goal because that's a
significant meaningful goal in their
business it doesn't have to be revenue
but it has to be quantifiable so I have
bold I have a goal to hit a million
YouTube subscribers on my channel it's
not just that that's the goal that I
warned them like when I accomplish that
then it's game over then I have one I
still respect and enjoy the process I
enjoy making the videos much more than
just hitting that goal but that goal
allows me to align my plan I have a goal
to hit gold in League of Legends and so
I have a plan to work on accomplishing
that and not all your goals need to be
growth-oriented sometimes the goal is
just maintaining your habits you know I
have a bowl to be a good husband if
that's your goal just in itself it's
hard to live up to because what does
that mean it's not specific enough and
so for me there's three things that I do
every day that's on my list that means
being a good husband things that are
important to my wife and important for
me and so I try to do these three things
every single day and when I do that then
I've kind of checked the boxes like I'm
doing the things that we need to do to
be a good husband and so when you can
quantify when you can get specific
around the goal you're much more likely
to accomplish that goal the trick then
become making sure that you have goals
that support you and being that best
version of yourself do you know what a
good picture looks like in the future do
you have a goal that is motivating and
meaningful to you so as an example let's
listen to a motivational DVD or CD years
ago and the guys talking about goal
setting and he's talking about write
down your goals and it's very energetic
write down your goals and you know if
you want to make a sculpture right down
right us make a sculpture you want to
make a painting right down make a
painting and so his energy influenced me
to want those things yeah I want to make
a sculpture room make a sculpture I want
to make a painting to look at how
exciting that sounds I want to make the
painting
and then when I came back to it at the
end of the day I don't really want to
make a sculpture I don't really want to
make a painting until having goals like
that didn't ultimately serve me until
that's the trick figuring out what are
the goals and if you accomplish these
things it's going to serve use planes at
the level that you want to pull you
having the clarity to understanding
where you want to go and writing those
things down because if you can
accomplish those things it means that
you're living the life that you want to
live and we can get really specific
again you're much more likely to follow
through than if you have no game plan
and Noble so the question today today is
I'm curious what are three of your goals
in your life or in your business what
are three goals that if you hit it's
going to make you feel really good and
it's a sign that your life and your
business are on track leave it in the
comments below will be curious to find
out and I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to do ha sipping in i hope i
pronounced that ok thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and i hope you're enjoying it
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso what's up believe nation for
those of you who want a little more
detail on creating goals and the
importance to your life and business I
think you're going to enjoy these
specials on this clip I want to talk a
little bit about goes on the light of
how do you lose a 37 pounds and write a
book I'm just going to kind of give you
that as an example for 24 years of my
adult life by choice I weighed well over
200 pounds I say by choice because you
see I have never accidentally eaten
anything
I mean has always been deliberate and
when I choose to eat too much today I
have chosen to weigh too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals and realize
your potential or you can choose not to
sassoon now if you choose not to set
them you got to understand Leslie
consequences are not going to be good
down the road for 24 years I was going
to lose that way as a matter of fact in
24 years I lost several thousand pounds
of weight hey mean if you already know
exactly what I'm talking about but it
wasn't until I wrote it down put a date
on it list of the obstacles i had to
overcome identify the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when i
did that that the goal became a reality
and I lost the weight for 10 to 15 years
I was going to write a book you know
anybody who's it going to do just a
whole lot of [ __ ] spokes I was going
to write a book but it wasn't until I
got busy writing the book and writing
the plan first before the book ever
materialized now if it sound like I'm
trying to sell you on heaven goes how
many of you are getting close already
how many of your being coming convinced
right quick like but you need to have
those gold there's no question about it
being mortal jcpenney many many years
ago said give me a stock clerk with a
gold and i'll give you a man will make
history but give me a man without a goal
and i'll give you a stock clerk now the
interesting thing is goes do not care
who has them let me give you a classic
example of the way they work in nineteen
hundred and fifty a war-torn devastated
the japan a nation who had lost an
incredibly high percentage of its young
men their cities were in ruins had been
bombed
but in 1950 they got together they
meaning industry and government got
together and set a goal the goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world during the 1950's in the
production of textiles in 1959 ladies
and gentlemen they accomplished that
objective in 1960 they said another go
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world in the production of Steel
now when you understand there's no iron
ore in Japan of any significance there's
no coal of any significance there we're
going to be the number one nation in the
world in the production of Steel it
seemed like an absurd goal and yet they
reached their objective they've taken
all of the steps in 1970 the Japanese
set another goal they said during the
seventies will be the number one nation
in the world in the production of
automobiles they missed it folks one
year it took them until nineteen eighty
nineteen eighty they said another gold
and this time they go was we're going to
be the number one nation the world in
the production of computers and
electronics yes indeed ladies and
gentlemen you absolutely must have those
goes the general principle is I am pro
goal right I am Pro like I'm Pro
parameters you know there's there's this
good story in the book about a woman in
the least blaha Christ was a serial
crafter and she makes all this stuff and
she serves it with the world and she's
incredibly prolific and her whole advice
is you know she said people are always
telling you to think outside the box she
says my advice is to get in the box
basically I'd make yourself a box like
make yourself these parameters these
goals whatever again it's not something
that's being imposed on you that's
really the clear point it's not like
someone saying here's your goal here's
what you should do know it's you things
that you select for yourself but I
believe I believe there's so much
possibility you know in those parameters
or in those constraints as we talked
about so whether it's like my goal is to
climb Mount Everest or maybe it's the
ten mountains or something and stages
are also good so stages or milestones
the levels in mario brothers you know
for me it was like 50 countries 100
countries you know then it was like
every continent once I finished you know
all of Africa that was a big thing so I
do think it's important to celebrate
small winds along the way